without it somehow doubt it
being able to spit out to montez's t.o.p
that's not allowed
can we
have you seen in seem that you can do
that oh no oh no oh no skip this is very
cool
raisi pretty little boot flexpay that's
crazy
damn okay
I didn't expect that
respective adopted who music this stuff
like or uh what else goes through that
toilets are maybe so pretty okay yeah
that which lies ahead does not yet exist
just beautiful
it speaks like an idiot though oh my god
nor will I have you this is
the edge of creation cool cloud lend me
your strength
let us defy destiny together
into alpha meme
this is incredible
like both just shockingly pretty and
really walk rd7
seconds till the end time enough for you
perhaps
but what will you do with it let's see
oh my god
is that it no okay it's not what I
expected mr. vice president
mr. president
convenient timing that's right
insert anime noises
[Music]
I could cost me the hell out of her I
really could you know I could do it
checks out
so pretty
you okay bud yeah
[Laughter]
where's everyone else
exactly
wait
I love him
you see that
[Music]
are you really gonna make me watch this
again though I've already been through
this sadness
yeah well
huh
[Music]
yeah thank you
[Music]
a lot of questions you're currently not
answering
how's she gonna hair like that though
still don't understand
now this I like the tile over they have
an animal Carson
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
my leg
[Music]
money
[Music]
I'll come back
look at me goosebumps so I can't not
what kind of gesture okay
[Music]
hmmm that's cool enough for us that was
cool long as he's still out there
I I thought you'd be mad we can't you
couldn't see you two shake out then the
club we wouldn't seen that we use what
if it's to be a hunt you could use a
nose
it's true
[Music]
I'm an to bastard wants to destroy the
whole planet that's me
an enemy of hearth is an enemy of
Adelaide's not a single wrinkle in him
nuts
you
almost there God we're almost there
you
well this is very well done
you
I miss it
the steel sky
you
I don't know what to make of any of this
I love the presence of Zach but I feel
like a lot of people aren't even gonna
know who that is
I'm extremely curious about what this is
going to mean for like the next episode
not that I feel like this game is
particularly episodic it was absolutely
a full game it's like they split it into
pots like Final Fantasy 13 and 13 - is
is more what it feels like then
restricted episodes absolutely I mean
the biggest change everyone doesn't know
is that zach is dead
like super super super dead and the
original canon now it looks like he's
either alive and this is like a split
timeline but it would mean that clouds
like everything that happens to cloud is
gonna be completely different I have
many questions because it seems like
even from what we see of Zach things
that are happening in a timeline we've
played a happening at the same rate in
his which would imply some kind of
timeline collision of sorts I think
which is what she was referring to Aaron
that is I feel like that also feeds into
the idea that whispers come from some
kind of alternate futures I don't know
this feels like some some endgame
business it's going on here which I
personally am extremely on board with I
am very cool with the presence of Zach I
love that character a whole lot I don't
know how other people are gonna feel
about this is super interesting to me
the goddamn beautiful video game I like
that very curious to see what everyone
else thinks let me know I guess show
does complicate things